cell phone videos captured a tornado
ripping the roof from a Los Angeles area
building oh my God
gusting winds sent debris flying almost
a dozen other buildings were damaged a
bunch of winning like crazy wind and uh
is there anything flying everywhere it
picked us up and threw us against the
fence as we were trying to get inside
for a shelter take a look at all this
Damage Done in an industrial sector of
Montebello by a tornado of all things at
least one person was taken to the
hospital hit by that flying debris
a similar scene near Santa Barbara
Tuesday evening when a tornado tore
through a mobile home park one person
was hurt more than two dozen of the
homes were damaged
in the San Francisco Bay Area the storm
is responsible for five deaths after
Hurricane force winds toppled trees and
plunged thousands into the dark